I just came together great
what's up fool what's up boo was so full
podcast right here with Felipe Esparza
brother realtor in Yemen sometimes he
says bars over here yeah yeah what's up
boo we just got bass up from we did we
did the one you wear this to your house
no no this week but you were Tarkan's
all right that's right I think what
Arkansas
dude podcastfast showed up hell yeah
dude this girl is a podcast there's some
guy from East Los Angeles who drove 45
minutes to go to the show how was it
dude dude it was tix hotel bro it was it
was like at that Tower from Superman
this show
yeah just flat roller well I was an
intern like like college town in a
community I like my up my hotel was
right like once I stepped out of my
hotel room and if I walk maybe like 10
feet I'm inside or the beginning of the
the entrance of the school but not oh
not the beginning of the scooper like ah
you know like the grass there's a
pathway to get to the to the school the
quad or whatever yeah that we have to
mezzanine yeah because the main entrance
is on the other side of the hotel room
but damn bro like ROTC building was not
to like when I started my building my
hotel room must have been part of the
college many years ago but now it's just
a hotel
oh cool cuz I see no you got a big old
welcome to huh a big old banner for you
yeah was rather read through it ripped
it here they were cool Bell I got booked
by a girl named Sid named Sidney uh-huh
african-americans do they're from the
school she from Arkansas Little Rock
it's for the big fro and everybody
there's Mulaney Oh bro but people
talking about Molina but some of them
know what stuff I do not all of them are
how you know the portray but we're a
friend aware the [ __ ] I say bro they
were no hard do they love nobody left
crying I do the hour that have do that
so what I don't know open or no feature
so and
ladies gentlemen Felipe Esparza I found
her but all that brush bro
there was just leaked out avoid you dog
no no eye contact through the show ended
well food ran out of there yeah dude
like I had a class to go to a circle but
oh god only like a half of the people
stood for photo that everybody left yeah
college is always cool things like that
nobody what about nothing never had a
tree like that though like a badass
comedian and the rest of the town got to
come - yeah really - anybody will free
to the town
this uh this blended couple there's a
trailer trash makes a good couple
Bhaskar
well ago hurricane with a crackers
nachos and NASCAR
that's what the NASCAR couple they are
they drove three hours oh really - come
on to the show and then I saw a man with
a real real long beard who showed up to
the show like a hillbilly do it with his
son like not a clean one like ZZ Top
no but if I had a bird inside now
they're all cool brother like they loved
the whole show
dude because that's what they just love
comedy dude and that's what's up and
shout-out to Russ Rafi made nephew soda
need a little ass kid bro he's going to
school Oh awesome cuz he's originally
from Arkansas right yeah college news
that's cool man oh that's cool
what's up fool man oh we got everything
here all West boos shut up - whoo San
Diego San Diego Guatemala shout out what
they do I have no idea and I don't know
what did you say right now before that
oh they're Arkansas okay bro
and then um it was like small town bro
it's right next to another town called
our Bentonville or I did up where
Walmart started
really yeah man Sam Walmart huh so
running right on the side of the school
I was like I woke up in the morning I
had half a Louie that's a good morning
dude lucky and I had to leave at noon so
my pride was at 1:58 so I had nothing to
do dude so I am I took care of that
Louie and then I started walking around
the school you know outside of could I
enter the school immunise there was at
least four at least four sorority
fraternity houses being rebuilt Oh huge
bro I liked a little like what Victorian
house attack huge manners
dude it was huge their house was better
than the place that did it
oh really huge bro and then we were
driving to the show like I wanted to see
like if there any left you know
construction workers right so with
brother are Mexican haha they came out
for the word yellow Hat's plays with
those safety hats the Oz books they all
say was tough to me when I read that and
you know it was so yeah bro oh hell yeah
I guess they stole those jobs bro so
anything they're just working just
working right yeah they probably know
the final you guys do a good job is that
is that the first time you see Mexicans
in Arkansas like that no I've seen up
everywhere bro K but I've never been to
markets yeah I never been Arkansas yeah
that's cool man
but don't allow Department know a lot of
them there at the show too hell yeah and
when I when I go and then I talk to the
subject but I'm New Brunswick I wouldn't
be another how we competed it and then
Asian and Latino are the the
fastest-growing minority in that town
out there right now hell yeah dude
I've only been Jersey once well that one
time we went we took what Koko's from
North Bergen the most ferry across the
NYC weather farther the city though
right yeah New Brunswick farther that's
it
oh yeah it's about an hour from the city
I think well that's how far with that
was it's not that far but it's not as
complicated to get over there we have to
flow we gotta fret to New Jersey
about five New York right you're finding
Newark nor okay Newark works up good
airport to fly into it used to be my
favorite because when I live when I live
down by the World Trade Center you could
catch a bus from the World Trade Center
to Newark Airport and it was thirty
minutes and it was like twenty bucks
it was just a straight shot otherwise
you had to take the train and a bus and
like it was annoying
but it's a good Airport where's the town
where the Sopranos are from is that made
up or they have such reals and all that
is that still rounding at Jersey City or
is that all my stuff I don't know where
they're from I'll just think about it so
I was in New Jersey parts of Cuba's bro
Coco's cousins I've been to Wallington
New Jersey one time with voodooed and
that was like it was a polish town yeah
yeah dude all they had was like a
bowling alley and once that was they had
like a deli and they had all those you
know like all right they have the Polish
burrito that yeah they had cow tongue
and all that was weird dude oh my god
grab a go boys or what yeah man they
were calling what I wouldn't know that
Chicago they had up stuff to pay they
had these out these are ground beef with
four like I boarded the guy you know
albondigas but they're wrapped and they
wrapped them with cabbage and they bake
up that's a Polish dish yeah that's
cabbage rolls cabbage rolls but Jersey
there was a girl named Paige it was run
in the place right there and she could
one of those polish burritos guys they
were cool bad bagel boys but there was
this play about that chain she knew I
liked you could tell like why they hire
her breaking the personality because uh
she spoke English and like you know New
Jersey New York I said let's just wasted
over to touch her to the basket
yeah dude she was running the places
like being a big big girl man but uh
very Authority I think by the way
Sopranos is technically Newark although
I don't think they really specify
but it says that there's a film that was
detailing with Sopranos background
written by David Chase and it's it's
called the many Saints of Newark and it
was set during the 60s during the Newark
riots what does that week about I don't
know they just purchased the story from
David Chase oh that was they purchased
that last month like a prequel to The
Sopranos right yeah so so surprised
Richie a prio buddy back huh
those all jacked you up real gonna be
young yeah probably
why not have a prequel oh boy what a
soprano father like how shaky record the
do they play them look good good yeah
when he would have those flashbacks when
he's going to therapy and rumor hitting
the ride you know who his father was
right he his father I think is the same
actor that came in to that bar concealer
is shut up the place bro and then they
[ __ ] put a vise over his head and I
popped out ah no dude yeah yeah who them
he was tough that dude ha hell yeah dude
give me a black tee shot a woman
everybody born then they tortured him
then I I popped out taking like a
soldier not for a new movie coming now
which one another movie about Pablo
Escobar another one there's another one
what's this about my love for Pablo it's
about a reporter that woman did his
assassin ended up killing right no I'd
really kill her but she helped literal
catch him yeah yeah she thought she was
she play the hot one that was like she
would get him well she was but he was
doing like the Robin Hood stuff like
buying electricity by schools for
everybody she was doing like the the
good ones you know but later on um we
was doing bad she was trying to get his
tattoo but isn't it work out that girl
okay I know you talking about so get
some starting who whose kids played the
girl some hi Penelope Cruz oh really
get the plane to dude always to work
open your eyes
yeah that's right that's right IV about
them and do but I mean after watching
narcos Pablo Escobar that's enough no I
did they children it's pretty much told
how it started ed I want to watch the
Spanish one which although you got
nobody it's better if you have one a
while I got more detail Pablo Escobar
series for watch follow Escobar but
right I like that I even like that one I
think I think that's the best Pablo it's
a good problem good Pablo he's very he's
very emotional
yeah I care for him and when they killed
him his boy his main guy and went or
whatever that the meanest ass they've
got he cries bro like you feel it like
okay he might take his side
well he was one of those strong SD but
you when he was a documentaries you want
that that our Pablo Escobar always hugs
and kisses sicarios and always gave him
money brought in with him guns he
treated him that there were kids but
that's like a treat kids bro if you
wanted to do you [ __ ] for you right
course not [ __ ] you know what my game
back can't really take care of you [ __ ]
you back so what do you think about that
you think it's a really badass movie
it's already been done it's already been
done but I will watch it when it comes
out on Netflix I have to see how bad to
you
maybe she Colombian accent oh my god
what is why not hit oh my god
but you know but they're gonna kill it
you know he had the long hair I'm sorry
the James Bond when he was the team's
Bond villain like not that oh is it the
last one the one before that the one
before that
yeah I like the window look what your
old [ __ ] [ __ ] I like them in Pirates of
the Caribbean row i watch that [ __ ] well
in a bucket well in a prequel bout that
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying that
was a badass let's take it back to what
haven here in a Spanish Armada or
[ __ ] a pirate yeah
badass [ __ ] right there man rather I
student I saw that seed I want to go
look it up bro - look how bad the
Spanish were there was a bad
[ __ ] they were gonna hold at all
of North America bro and Canada - they
[ __ ] lost to the British the last
[ __ ] 33
yeah yeah they were to do they were rich
off Mexico of course dude all that gold
going through [ __ ] Tulum that and
silver dude get about it there's so many
gold came through Mexico huh about gold
is torn America but if they say when the
Spanish guys deliver they found it
people they want it when the Spanish got
to the Aztecs little kids would play
with gold like make [ __ ] out of it like
play-doh dude like og like soft real
gold pure gold that's right a wrestling
also to light those thankful I think
yeah I don't know if Bob was a movie we
saw we started documentary that like he
one of the Spanish rubbed one of the
Aztecs kids and they had like crystals
of gold on it
yeah little but didn't even know bro
flakes flakes they just landed on their
way a man leading to meet you Picchu
with a pattern showed up way up up in a
mountain the giggle fool [ __ ] care now
that out that the Peruvian thing meetcha
what it's made on the coca leaves yeah I
have no idea and they said they give
this circle for the glass of gold really
in an empty they were all put in their
eyes that's let me show it off the words
to a new town bro and he won a further
pass it out Louise nobody shot what
brought it and you go there they got a
bunch of ease old buddy how much is this
are we giving it away man I'm about to
come up with this town it's like when
Joe East and we were talking to Joe Diaz
any and what his podcast is there a
shorter oh he's here and he showed up he
showed up to to Boulder bro
and usually you just know how to take
advantage of nice people it was wide
open down
wide open so just took all that go
brother
that'd be good yeah that's the old book
yeah I did the bow with the dudes yeah
my doctor got me was so full so then we
went to Eric RJ's birthday party yeah
that was crazy I was crazy bro that food
he dressed like a woman had it okey said
yeah bro so that I forgot body slam day
for the rest of shoulder her body
slammed over that kids in here address
were you guys there for the pudding
wrestling yeah I didn't see that they
had a mud wrestling broke but it without
putting in chocolate but it was really
all they emptied out of other restaurant
in Echo Park and they put up another yes
so that happened and then I was supposed
to host a play but you know it was chaos
oh he brought him in my job come on
Mandy
and then you win and sage threw that one
back interest so we we went around the
other side but we didn't catch you
yeah I knew this party was gonna be
crazy but I knew I know that I was
expecting everything that I saw even
though three people were walking around
a party matter the mosh pit no the old
black duty though without with the third
our baby album nobody wanna bar speed
huh more salad dance with that fool
right
give me the creeps tone yeah I just you
know I saw my top hat but nobody even
noted all that naked men around yeah man
but though but that was kind of gross
too though cause like like I always
thought there we go to a nudist colony
those would be the type of people you
see yeah yeah it's not gonna be no
good-looking people either be nobody
there for bangbros
nobody's a barrio girls just a bunch of
fans just a bunch of fans brother Oh
[ __ ] uh the other lowrider magazine it
up north read that lowrider but
otherwise yeah mass speed wise lowrider
was theirs to be old school on bro cocky
over what back in the days it was Q and
B oh you remember that one oh I told you
power when I tried to go back to the
hood bro like I'm gonna rehab or come on
our school and off your old I bet that I
know bro just came on a prison - but I
like maybe like I would say old but back
to him I was older than [ __ ] 1730 I
know huh he's not your good bad bro but
the u-238 people my age old dude but I
was 17 everyone else did when I was a
junior high school I will see high
schools do this I'm like yeah they're
older do they dude I don't know as a
little kid those folks had four must
actually suggest [ __ ] I don't wish to be
this hot ass chick right a woman hot
brought up a woman boss junior high and
in high school there my brother lying
bromelain yo the holidays are around
players like him you on Street low not
streetwise she wear the clothes my bad
Alex was so fooled this weekend
NUMA be a New Brunswick New Jersey at
the stress factory where the three goes
Johnny and his new
use April 12 to the 14 April 20th that's
right for 20 Albuquerque New Mexico and
Ysleta resort with illegal tourists
Johnny and tell B that's almost sold out
that's almost sold out people Cinco
DeMayo Thunder Valley Casino in
Sacramento area Lincoln with Rodrigo
Torres Johnny and Marcela May 10 through
12 Salt Lake City and wiseguys the brand
new jordan landing location jordan
landing okay 20 minutes from Salt Lake
we go Johnny Tobey May 19 I'm coming
back it's been a while but this time I'm
doing a bigger set Ignacio Colorado at
Sky youth casino with Rodrigo and Larry
Baba's murder that fool wrote a bunch of
drug for me bro hell yeah dude
they were all birds that won't bother
you two and we have new dates that we
added to the bad decision tour
all right table big ones they're on
public to the public April 20th but for
you guys our listeners
it'll be April 17 next Tuesday through
the 19 password for the fan presale is
oh oh L find the tickets at Felipe
WorldCom slash tour starting April 17 on
sale to the public for 20 our Paso Texas
June 22nd
San Antonio June 23rd Amarillo Texas
August 10th McAllen Texas
August 11 Lubbock Texas August 24th oh
the red of Texas August 25th Las Vegas
Nevada I'm coming back September 14 baby
we're at Nevada oh that's gonna be hard
rock hard rock cafe that's Mexican
Independence weekend so doing this we
chose to go on the Friday instead of
Saturday because there's always a fight
on Saturday so Dallas Texas October 12
Houston Texas October 13 San Francisco
the
per second that's why the purpose is to
the the uber dealer no now Warfield
Warfield right the Warfield theater take
that punch line we don't need your ass
legendary we don't need your ass I told
you will never need your personal San
Francisco [ __ ] you we're doing the
[ __ ] water for your [ __ ] ass take
that you piece of [ __ ] never book me
November 3rd San Diego take that other
comedy club in San Diego you know who
you are
you [ __ ] alright we're not bitter can
I put a little bit arterian profit that
wins I want hobby there it weighs on 1
April 19 people the pre pre 20th am I
show up to that are you the problem you
have a 19th oh all right man some of you
guys man ok to remain that one God all
theories huh hey Bo you want to look
good in your underwear I do every and be
comfortable tear my underwear folding
all those second for style bro check out
my new these other ball huggers
you know we getting loose bro and Italy
you were for too long and they start
sweaty and they going up your leg start
cutting your ass or your wear boxer
briefs they start rising and [ __ ] then
you took a bomb it's like it went
through size again ok I've been wearing
me unleased for a long time bro first of
all cover they give it to me in but I
wouldn't buy them if they were in the
echo store we did buy a couple pairs
yeah we and they're like they're like
Karma it's like wearing um it's like
wearing up comforable biker shorts their
boxer briefs there a boxer briefs bro
but you never when used to watch them
bad how tight you were and you're asking
yourself man that [ __ ] bad knees a
little more more room in the front but
this one's come without a room bro I
used to dress like a genie huh yeah but
wait with a biker or whatever
what's up y'all 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee me I'm just giving cheesy all
of the other undies or your money back
I don't know you're gonna stand these on
the words back paper they'll take your
money back me on these adventurous Perez
in designer limited edition new patters
are released every week so far what
better but I just pick colors for you
okay you don't like ones that are all
brought no one could notice me at least
have an exclusive offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchasers when you
pursue me on these me undies you get 20%
off and free shipping we are busy so
show your lovely underwear they offer
one half percent satisfaction guarantee
to get you 20% off your first pair of
free shipping a 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies calm foo me
oddly calm /foo that's me on these you
and di es like me or dice me on these
doggone / - those are me undies night
might was so fool because we go Taurus
right here in the house don't worry
about me man we got a living legend
right what's up fool she's got a hole we
gonna I guess my hair bro oh man a guy
that I've been a long time ago by
another girl we had her - OH - juice
juice we were in Hawaii we got food no
we're just Hawaii but we're in Hilo yeah
man so guide you over there because of
the glass stuff yeah murder murder yeah
shoutout to Ari yeah Hollywood are we
Hawaii Hawaii no I've known him for very
long time because of the photos and I
got into a fight one time bro our face
with a partly they took my facebook for
like three days cuz it's bad chola right
she was posting all all of his photos
from my book and not tagging nobody kept
a chola she was Kate likes bro
people getting feet on her page
age and she was getting more more friend
follower than me lying over there
profiling and had to listen you fat
[ __ ] these photo belong to Estevan
Oriol or real or the old rest a little
link and everything block me and their
Facebook took me down for being a
harasser but then IIIi I stopped a fight
but then I realize everybody's doing it
so it was point little bro
so yeah I hit her with my book and then
I walked I went to me and juice which
are like a sketch comedy group you know
be here man you're doing skill you're a
filming skills obese kids so we went to
go look for a bunch of lost you ever
went to a bunch of studio bro is that
that one time you got you guys a free
space yeah and then we went to meet
mister cartoonist Emma
oh yeah they gave me a sweater yeah you
had the Joker brands too and gotta tell
ya the blue one the blue one and dr.
early like this I still got it but uh
when I when I met you I remember you
you were you were like the only do the
dog you don't the only Chicano right the
only thanks again American and that's
three right six feet you were on yeah
six in Matteo now there's they ran
everybody out of there it's all like you
know hipsters and [ __ ] walking around
with their little poodles and drinking
$10 cappuccinos and vegan wraps and all
that [ __ ] it was an extension of Skid
Row yeah well they're by a book that I
wrote about rebus by a books about how
to roll up a burrito rich about another
hipster like what do you hipsters know
they know what other hipsters like like
I would never like
I would never think about writing right
[ __ ] doing a picture a coffee book
just on burritos bro or showing you how
to wrap a burrito right oh how awful you
know
and then list his favorite burrito
places was the wrong the West I had down
and him put it out there because
he knows these food I've gotta buy that
[ __ ] info let's see I wouldn't start
I'll write a book about how to roll of
tacos man open up - your dog I know we
don't do that [ __ ] - fire bro check it
out we can have it on the website and I
read about you that I'm you started off
with as the tour manager right for San
Franci oh yeah for a house of pain
originally in 92 oh so was that like
that was sick because at that time
everybody thought they were black guys
singing jump around and when we'd come
up to the club it was you know three
white guys and me in there like what the
[ __ ] these guys coming in here you know
the [ __ ] are they and then we hit the
stage and play jump around and the crowd
go crazy [ __ ] man I didn't know y'all
was white you know they were going crazy
but for that little bit of moment that
we had a song and they were going nuts
how could I not know bro they were not
white broad they mentioned only white
guys drop back over all those flying
sounds like white boys doing high
Everlast was like you know just mob in
the stage with mob money lent me in I
remember that album was huge stars yeah
I was a badass out it was huh yeah we
did like a promo tour first in a van it
was just me and the three guys and then
in the record label reps and we'd go
around the colleges and college radio
shows and do interviews and stuff and by
the end of that summer we went on a tour
with Beastie Boys and we had seven
minutes on the show with them on the
stage and the song was blowing up and we
got kicked off that tour and then weird
like too rowdy for the Beastie Boys so
we got kicked off that to her and then
you're a Christian now yeah then this
after that the song blew up and we just
took off and toured around the world
with that a first and second album and
then I switched over to Cypress Hill in
94 and my first show with them was
Woodstock 94 Wow - that [ __ ] was huge
yeah I wired it go bro oh why what's it
lying on I'll go the t-shirt the rage
everybody was there goes that kind of
kills it hurt it was off the hook
Henry Rollins played before us and then
Cyprus came out and just when the crowd
went crazy for you know like a straight
hour damn ripping [ __ ] out like the I
guess it a train there before and they
put plywood all over the the floor it
was really muddy that we yeah and the
guy all the crowd just started taking
the wood off and they're holding it up
and people were jumping up on the wood
and they're like crowd-surf you know
pieces of plywood yeah so it's pretty
pretty cool show to see you know how did
it out how's the paid know about you I
was friends with mugs in around in 1989
in mid mugs and the other guys from
Cyprus in Cyprus have and then hanging
out mugs all those years until in 92 he
was like eh I got a new group coming out
that I want you to uh you know to or
manage and all you have to do is make
sure that they go to the show on time
and do their interviews and that's
pretty much what the job is and I was
like yeah sure because I was only doing
construction and working Dork the
working like the VIP doors at night at
clubs and what clubs like the trendy
ones that were around back then doublets
nose it was like the it was a brain full
house he hired different spots you know
like like on a Friday night we do a club
here you know so there was no like set
place and it was just like the different
clubs all over the the city back then
and I got the you know hit up by mugs to
do that job and I told my other boss is
a you guys you know what do you think of
this and they're like go for it man you
can always come back and work here you
know you're a good worker so I I took
the chance and never went back never
[ __ ] hammered and
Nellore you know how to tell somebody
they weren't on the guesses again it was
pretty fun you know toured around the
world with like 44 countries and
multiple times and sought a lot of cool
[ __ ] and did a lot of cool [ __ ] and
that's kind of like when I started
taking photos as in the beginning when I
was touring house of pain and I was
building a lowrider at the same time and
my pops was like amen
you live you know pretty cool lifestyle
like you're low right in East LA and
then you go you know on tour and you're
living like a rock star life you know
you should document that and at first I
was kind of like shy in order to break
out a camera I kind of felt like only
like paparazzi's and tourists had
cameras and it wasn't a good look and
then I busted it out here and there and
got more comfortable within little by
little and you know now today that's all
I do
you know you know no more touring or
that kind of [ __ ]
well the first camera you were using the
first one I was using was my Pops's
Minolta 35 millimeter but then I was
able to buy you know my own [ __ ] I got a
Canon a 135 millimeter and I just rolled
with that I still have that to this day
your dad was a photographer too right
yeah Eddie Burke doriel he's uh he still
takes pictures every day downtown he
rolls around he lives downtown and he
walks through there every day
do you take photo for the paper no he
just takes him for his self
he's retired images are so striking all
everything I see whether it's a man or a
woman or a car or whatever it is like
what is it that makes you decide I want
to photograph that or I have to capture
it what is it that jumps out at you just
you know different things the you know
you'll just be walking down the street
and something will catch your eye and
your bag oh that's cool or you know
she's prettier he looks cool and that's
a nice car you know just different stuff
and
because you don't always take pictures
of pretty people and sometimes it's
people who are beat down or you're
homeless and that was how it was back in
the 90s you know there's always there
was always people in the car in the car
culture like the lowrider world and then
there was like gangster guys and then
although the girls would come to you
know check out all the other cool
gangster guys so they would come they
leave the baby daddies at home and just
put the kids weird are you developing
your own film
- no I tried doing that before I went to
school and tried that [ __ ] but it's too
much work it's too hard and like there's
professionals that do it and I just let
them do it you know that was the part of
turning off of anything bro did not read
with the better be part yeah well I'm
gonna be a photographer over there I
think about being that dark ass room and
about how much money I'm gonna waste
it's dropping all this stuff spilling
water yeah somebody my mom coming
because you know ok chemistry said [ __ ]
yeah open the door and just ruin
everything you got exposed where did you
grow up at I was born in Santa Monica at
st. John's and I grew up around the west
side for pretty much all my youth and
then I moved to Hollywood when I was
about 18 and stayed out there and then
moved to the downtown area with my
partner mr. cartoon we moved down there
around 95 96 and stayed down there for a
long time you do it you all grew up with
him mr. cartoon no I met him in 92 we're
at a record release party for the
penthouse players and one of my friends
Donnie Charles rest in peace he took me
there he was a manager at that time of
WC in the Med circle and cartoon had
done the artwork for that album
cover and when we went in there was back
in those days if you went to like a
hip-hop function it was like about 90%
black people there and then a couple of
Jewish guys and a couple mixing guys and
right when we walked in there was like
you know the record label guys you know
we're in the corner you could see them
and we looked over to the left and there
was cartoony as I ain't come here I want
you to meet another one of my Mexican
homies so I went over there and just
hung out with cartoon and and we got all
good and talked about you know different
[ __ ] that we liked you know low riding
and music and everything and I gave him
like a House of Pain promo tape you know
like the single promo cassette tapes and
I go hey man this is this you know group
I'm gonna be working with check it out
I'm gonna go to Japan and you know when
I get back all I'll you know hit you up
and at that time he was gonna go to
Japan Tunes and do some murals on some
lowriders and you know people would trip
out of there like man you know I didn't
know they have lowriders in China you
know but it's you know he's going to
Japan because they were deep in the
low-riding thing in the late eighties
they started it and so you know that was
one thing that we had in common was you
know the low riding thing and then
traveling and according to Japan and the
hip hop thing cuz he was working on
album covers for logos and he did a
thing for kid frost back then and he was
doing one for MC ran so we were both
tied into the music industry and no
writing and traveling so it was cool so
how long you two
oh that like man like when you when you
walk into like what how's the pain or
separates here and like it I know what
they're big in Europe but they're also
bigger South America too they go crazy
over there yeah a Brazil yeah like
chillin and in Caracas and Brazil and
all those places Argentina they were
going nuts every time we go out there's
like
it's like a different level you know
like we're pride harder yeah yeah like
the in in Argentina if they respect you
and they like you they spit at you and
wonder they go yeah yeah I was uh I was
shooting wind a we American Hansen
opened up before us and and I kept
feeling feeling like [ __ ] hitting me
like from behind you know looking around
on the ground and nothing was like
falling but it felt like little things
like we're hitting the back of my head
and my sweatshirt is [ __ ] it's like what
the [ __ ] is she got a guy hold and then
I started looking like like I would see
like there was that like a net against
where the speakers were and you would
see like spit coming down the hitting
the net I was like and then I saw him
like you know Marilyn Manson he's a
little freaky he's up there and he's
just wiping it all in him and just yeah
pouring wine on himself and you know
getting into it and then I went back to
the back of the stage and I told the
guys be realist and I was like
amen they do this crazy [ __ ] here they
spit on you if they like you and they
respect in there like oh we've gotta do
something about that like what can we do
I don't know tell whoever's announcing
you know back in art in our country you
know that's disrespectful you know that
it's the opposite and and they told me
like what's right you know we'll try to
tell them but you know it's a custom
here so you know don't get mad at people
started [ __ ] spitting loogies on you
Evita started it Lucas - yeah like you
know they were just spitting like little
spray [ __ ] were saving on Brooke wasters
day yeah they were saving up all back
was up
nobody wants to go first and Sarge they
tell 48 well you go cause back to back
they put a [ __ ] loogie what happened
bro those fools go onstage like that or
like what you guys on a Braille group
yeah you know we went out there and you
know of course they some of the people
were like [ __ ] that we do here you know
you know just something that you you
know like when you travel you gotta
adapt adapt to other customs of
different you know cultures so that was
one of them damn bro letting you spit up
a cop or just tell no good team oh the
merit badge
how was a Mexico City when you guys went
over there the first time they saw the
brother first time we went there there
it was for a video it was from how I
could kill a man in Spanish that's when
you directly and I directed it and that
was pretty much the first time Cypress
that ever went to to Mexico at all so
when we got there what the [ __ ] you guys
doing here you know there we haven't
heard her no show or nothing so we came
to film a video and we met a lot of
people in the bars real quick and before
you know they're like okay you know do
you need anybody were like yeah yeah
yeah we need as many people as we can
get so within like two days we had just
had a couple hundred people ready to you
know roll around with us in the video
lowriders lowrider bikes you know yeah I
seen that [ __ ] cuz that's was all like
in the zocalo and [ __ ] and he had a
crazy scene where you had the military's
like come up and then they went in
Reverse yeah it was like it was [ __ ]
badass dude yeah that's when they come
out to lower the flag and take the flag
off and take it back inside right there
and I filmed all that with a bull like
16 millimeter camera so it was like you
know all you know real old-school film
and that was before the whole digital
thing so uh it was a trip you know how
did you jump from photographer to the
red
a friend of mine he just passed away his
name was Martin he he was a guy from
London and he he was doing like a
documentary on our car club and he was
like eh he had this 8 millimeter camera
and he had a digital like mini DV camera
and he was like hey you know try and
shoot this in the enemy this the 8
millimeter cameras you know make your
images come to life and I was like well
okay I'll try it so I'll go do photo
shoots and then I'll grab that camera
and shoot a little bit of it here and
there and when I developed the footage
that's when I assembled like a little
tape of my footage and I gave it to the
record labels and they were like hey you
know well because when you go to try to
get a job doing directing for music
videos they go ok cool this is the first
video you want to do can you show us you
know what other music videos you've done
so that we could see your work and
you're like well this is the first one
so of course I don't have any you know
from before you know this is it so I had
to make a little tape of footage that
I've shot and show them and put this put
the song to it and then they're like
okay go for it you know but it's kind of
hard to get into that it was back then
it was really hard to get into that
industry you've been getting into movies
they're like oh you've done 200 music
videos and a hundred commercials well
you know you want to direct a movie yeah
yeah yeah you know I'd love to
well can you so show us what other
movies you've done like no I want to I
want to get into it you know I've just
done music videos and commercials and
[ __ ] like that they're like well we want
to see what movies you've done you know
if you want to get into movies I want to
say what I mean let me just saw them
together
maybe shoot my 90 minute video yeah yes
they make it hard for you you know but
well now now it's a different game you
know you could go to
spying by a camera and make your own
movie and do it like that but back then
it was a lot harder than other people to
podcast all his Beca when you're saying
like it wasn't digital it's all analog
so you were actually cutting right yeah
yeah they had like a reel-to-reel yeah
yeah that's cool no the video is very
even made that way back then I thought
about videos being made like then I
meant a cartoon phone cover no this is
my friend dopey he does a lot of tattoos
and I was just showing him you know
different way he could make some money
and you know I say you can make a couple
little products you know t-shirts phone
covers or whatever and charge 104 oh
yeah what's up fool chillin huh how you
livin good man well the last time I
watch your office well I walked in there
during the armed the art walk when you
were still on six feet huh and we had a
little gallery for yeah the gallery and
I when I bought my t-shirt the bicycle
yeah I bought a badass hoodie from you
my son took it though all your photos
not just these at the guy with a bubble
I which I liked the beer and I had one
of a kid crying yeah yeah that's one of
my favorite photos yeah and I'm but but
that particular time when you were doing
that movie when we were dealing with
Pacino and De Niro the Righteous Kill
Righteous Kill
yeah yeah our other posters for the more
things they had like a party there right
yeah yeah we had a we had like two
pop-up shops there we had like four
stores there us and a couple of our
friends and we had to pop-up shops there
and one of them we would do events for
and we did have been for Righteous Kill
there because we had done
like we did a spec job for the poster
and they're like you can try to do the
poster but you know we already hired
somebody to do it but if we like yours
and use it we could pay you you know so
we're like whoa [ __ ] it you know if we
don't get paid at least we got to shoot
you know Robert De Niro and all that
[ __ ] so we had a you know trying our
best and we ended up getting the job and
they liked it and they paid us and it
was they're like hey you know what else
would you guys want to do we said let's
do like a little pop-up thing for for
the movie and we did that and it came
out good so that was just a couple
little things we did with them how many
Apple box is it but you know Stan yes
shoes that are having the Apple box how
is he
I don't know I'd say 555 I David maybe
smaller yeah five three or something
I've I met him in New York he's like
he's like this
yeah pleasure to meet you Lisa he was so
nice though he wanted he this is before
phone cameras but he was gonna take a
photo with my family was visiting me in
New York and he they ran out of well
actually they ran out of battery there
they go and then we had another
opportunity he ran down the street to
catch up with us cuz I said no I could
take it and then realize that the memory
on the digital camera was full and I
said forget it I know he said well I
tried
how tall was he really short
yeah yeah he's he's pretty pretty sure
they're cool while I was there oh yeah
they were super cool like tight
I knew De Niro's stepdaughter from New
York Draya and then I
made a Pacino at-at at a birthday party
in in Hollywood at the mean club I think
it was for us well I was I was gonna do
these photos of him back then so I just
kind of broke the ice I told me I met
you at this party I told didn't you're
right you know I know you're a
stepdaughter and that kind of broke ties
to where they were cool right off the
bat you know so it wasn't just like you
know guy doesn't know anybody
you know meeting them and it's it it
kind of helps when you have something to
talk about other oh yeah yeah like a
stand right here so I could take a cool
picture of you know that's what's up
that's badass but I was in my head I was
thinking like shooting those two guys
was like a goal of mine you know I used
to tell my wife if I shot if I ever shot
like after I shot Dennis Hopper I told
my wife I ever shot Al Pacino or Robert
De Niro I I could quit and I'd be cool
you know I go around at home deep or
whatever [ __ ] but I ended up shooting
both of them and obviously I didn't quit
yeah there she is your wife right there
with a shotgun yeah yeah that's why I
have to get home on time I come home I
make the make the dinner I do the
laundry
practicing my head with the with the
barrel of that somebody asked a question
here and one of the people watch and
said do you feel that hipsters and the
new artsy people are exploiting the life
and of adios just to make money oh yeah
you know the the they like it you know
what it's kind of hard to to you know
can like you can't control that [ __ ] you
know like there was a you know people
would be like oh yeah these [ __ ] are
getting the Chicano tattoos on them and
they're not from the hood or whatever
and you got a you know somebody told me
you know what American people going
tattoo dragons and koifish on them and
they don't letters yeah they never been
to China or they don't go to to Japan or
you know they're not over there doing
[ __ ] you know so everybody just but I
guess they see different cultures and
they like it and they they don't live it
but they can get that part of it you
know without having to go through any of
the drama you know right back then those
tattoos you only got him in
presidentship
right yeah you had like you know someone
know someone or you had to earn them or
something like that but like I don't
wear the pro but I see a spider web or
elbow I know at that time like a [ __ ]
certain things that yeah like peacocks
you don't see that no more like no bad
my friend dopey I was telling but he hey
man nobody asked for like peacock tail
no I haven't even nobody's ever brought
that up you know because they it's just
like that's kind of one of those things
like oh they're old-school bro
macaques spider wave on the elbow what's
another one man the Virgin Mary of
course
yeah hate to be a good one Jesus Christ
in the back with a cross yeah anything
you know but there before they was late
but nobody getting a sailor girl no more
that's just the way winner shark who a
lefty the anchors are here for a pop-by
yeah everybody was real people more
Bruce people what their head to like his
bruised up now people want hickeys
tattooed on them now let me call my
sister to give us he get to a white boy
whatever that he get a say year
Orion right at least give me the cue for
another time I didn't give you the cue
no you can wait there you go okay
everybody
you gonna turn about hiring somebody man
but you don't want to be tired of hiding
your cars there no your sisters your
your father-in-law son or your flakes
family members broken her flake they
tell you they don't even call you
worried they call you at your mom's
house and he leaves to work already
Todd I'm not gonna come you know so so
man you know basically mondo right how
many time on do fire people bro for bad
exterminating jobs or jobs falling off
the ladder
bro there's Apple can they be a ninja
never lets it go she got me to do the no
I don't what's up fools typically Arab
man with zip recruiter is different man
it it learns what you're looking for it
then I find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply for
a job in fact 80% of employers who hold
posted job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day and zip recruiter doesn't
stop there
they even spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you never
miss a great match never business of all
sides is a trusty recruiter for their
hiring needs right now my listeners can
try it
zip recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruiter comm /foo
that's zip recruiter comm /foo
zip recruiter comm /foo zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire you never know
bro that megaman guy i need an extra
guys draw
yeah Mario Mario 10 but right now Mario
Lisson it twists about getting motivated
bro
and it's a trip though because not now a
lot of dudes are doing like photos like
lowrider shows on black and white and
like you know gangsters on the street
and stuff but I mean not good it's kind
of like yeah you're like you gave I mean
kind of like you know people trying to
do what you're doing yeah yeah and what
you did yeah there was people that did
it before me and there's a lot of people
doing it after me but I just think I
brought my own twist to it you know and
I and I think that uh I don't know I
feel like I work harder than a lot of
people that are doing what I do you know
they come I'm out there I get up you
know early as hell go to sleep late you
know like you know they they say hard
work pays off you know so for me I just
as soon as I wake up I'm I'm on the move
you know and other people they'll be
they'll do the same type of photography
but they'll sit at home waiting for
somebody to come and kick their door
down with a suitcase full of money and
be like here you know you don't have to
do [ __ ] you're you all you you know you
did the photos that's all you got to do
you know it's like but it's not like
that there's a lot of stuff that's going
on in the background
yeah like 90% of my work is what I what
I'm doing when I'm not doing the photo
shoots you know that's just like that's
the easiest part is that one day you're
doing the photo shoot the hardest part
is you know up until that point and
after that you know it's like you know
what do you do after you for me what I
do after I shot Robert DeNiro now pacino
which was like my biggest goal in in
what I do and it was like okay well cool
you did that now what you know you got
to keep going you know or or really quit
and I've just been going nonstop you
know this year I'm working on I put out
two books on my own and this year um my
goal is to put out three books at the
end of the year so that's what I'm
working towards now
and I got a bunch of my I have like 82
photos up at the new hotel figure wrong
yeah we just stated we stopped there we
saw yeah we do they yeah and I'm trying
to be the first resident artist there
where they give you a room for three
months to do whatever you want in there
and it's most of the times it's like a
painter or writer that's cool so it's
cool this is the first time it's gonna
be a photographer and my goal is to do a
book a month while I'm in there that's
badass that's you know go in there and
scan all the photos and pick everything
and lay it out and then it'll be done
and give it to the publishers and they
can go from there and so you just have
that dedicated focus time to like be in
that room and work that's cool so the
thing I think that's different from your
stuff versus like these people who you
could tell are copying your style or
subject matter the thing is like all
your photos they don't have any judgment
that's what I like about them like you
might photograph a crack addict looking
you know hitting a pipe you might but
you don't feel judging them you don't
feel you don't like like yeah looking
down on them you took away all the
ugliness of that person it's pure human
being yeah that's from being down there
all those years you know like your I've
had I had I've had family members and I
have family members that are homeless
and then and live like that and it's
it's hard to you know judge somebody
that you've seen somebody that you love
and your own family members living like
that you know it's like hard to you know
I I'm around people and I hear them say
say [ __ ] like that all the time or like
look at them [ __ ] you know look how
they [ __ ] live they're like [ __ ]
rats living in the street and you know
they just say a lot of [ __ ] but when
you've had family members living like
that you're like
I just keep it to myself I don't want to
get into argument but it's kind of like
you know it just makes you think like
[ __ ] I like instead of being like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're talking
about somebody you know I keep it
personal and to myself that which family
members that I have lived like that you
know I keep that to myself but the first
thing you want to say is man go [ __ ]
yourself you know you're talking about
my family memory you know they live like
that but then you it just makes you be
humble and think about it and like
you're like man I wonder how that family
members doing you know I want to go by
and see them you know it's just like you
know always like brings a brings it like
right in your face whereas that's what I
think about instead of being like you
know hey you know like judgmental
yeah like or just like you know sticking
up for them or whatever I'd rather just
put more time into it you know go help
more people or go see how my family
members are that are you know because
you know like right now is probably the
most I've ever seen homeless people on
in LA yes there's this a crazy community
of people that live in RVs or motorhomes
they're parked like twenty or thirty of
them on a block and they have like their
own little community and then there's
all the people in the tents you know
that it's it's crazy I never seen it
like how it is right now and yeah their
whole city's down there now yeah and we
are back in there one of the richest
cities in the world and we have the
worst homeless problem in the world you
know yeah man it don't make no sense in
hell now and I seem to park he said on
an interview like 20 years ago he's like
man I don't know how [ __ ] live
in a mansion and they drive out their
driveway and there's homeless people at
the you know on their Street like how
does that how does that work you know
can you think about it like all the
people that have all this money like but
then the people that are homeless like
some of most of them don't want help
you know like we have family members
that will tell us hey we know where you
live when we want to have one we want
help or we want to change will come and
will come and knock on the door and
that's like [ __ ] up you know you're
like man you'd rather to sit there and
struggle and and not know where you're
gonna get your next food from or be cold
at night and then just to you know come
and get some help from your family you
know it's it's kind of a trippy thing
you know but that's where the mental
illness kicks in and you don't know you
know man you're not trained to help
those kind of people you know some of
them are crazy man I still don't know
how they haven't had their meds in
forever or they never liked taking their
meds which is why yeah or they were
dropped off from Orange County - but
that and that's funny because with you
know every government and all that
that's something that they just like
overstep they don't even look at that
yeah
humanitarian if you go to Sam San Julian
and 6th Street - my spot the next block
over is like the biggest cop station in
LA
yeah they're right across the street
they come out of their door and they
don't they see that [ __ ] all day every
day and you know what are they gonna do
bust all those guys for a $2 rock you
know or $5 bag of heroin right and then
like those guys go to prison and you
know like how does ya help this [ __ ]
they the war the world's drugs is lost
right across the street yeah yeah right
out the front door the other time like
maybe like eight years ago or maybe even
longer before that that they were deal
about making a movie you in cartoon yeah
what happened to that nothing I don't
want to use the money huh well juice it
brother they want to do one yeah I got
put on the shelf
yeah but everybody write it yeah they
had a writer who wrote it off
no please one direct yeah I wondered
direct and then we had the writer and he
was there for like seven years he wrote
a new script every every year and he got
paid on that broke
and they said you know we're not
interested but they came back and they
said we want to do another movie based
on like low riding we want to add more
low riding into it and they did low
riders and me and cartoon were hired to
do executive produce and consulting on
it and that that's a movie that came out
last year David Longoria Evan Longoria
Demian Bichir and you know that that one
came out and did it a little bit in the
in the movie theaters but I don't know
you know but I don't know how that whole
business works though and I never saw
that movie though I remember not the
more you talking about the low I didn't
move you're talking about
I remember know the kid I think I saw a
low rider movie where the low rider guy
loved the white chick - Lee probably
back in the days bro and he had to cross
a line and get jumped I think maybe back
talking about that movie you know the
one there was you know closest to it was
a bull of our nights whatever our night
was bad [ __ ] yeah there was that was
like the closest you can get to the
movie that we did last year
Boulevard nice we just try to make it
look you know the best that it could
look visually you know bringing the
right cars put in the right you know
situations you know trying to consult
them like you know this would have this
would ever happen or this isn't real and
you know but you know Hollywood does the
things their their way and you can't you
know intervene you know so their money
is their idea they're hiring you you're
you know you're just like hired help
kind of you don't make no decisions
we're gonna make the lead a next NASCAR
driver who was to raise in the streets
now
so to this day you haven't directed a
film n-no no I'm working on it still
working on it but you know like I said
it's hard they they always wanna they
say you know
show us your work what you've done you
know show us a short movie or something
like that like they don't think that you
doing a music video or you directing
some documentary or anything is is
enough for is enough of a resume to do a
movie what's-his-face got three movies I
think he did the Charlie's Angels film
was his first one Mick G he was a video
director he yeah Charlie's Angels was
the first real movie that he had done
and then he got like three or four
movies after that the residue and
they're beautiful yeah I don't know how
good they are as movies but they were
popular enough for him to get more he
did RISM what you say RZA did of that
movie don't write it first movie with um
master p dope was his i think it was
like dope I love dope I like doing up
the one that was most you know that
connected to me most about our other
idea yeah no not that dope Master P no
Master P dear make that movie with the
dope dealer
it's called dope okay nothing razor
redirect now it's kind of like Al Capone
meets a lot of more other movies
remember when a boat fishing came out
how many movies came out yeah a similar
poll fiction yeah
and rode the board dogs like a genre
right yeah that movie was called walk
proud that was Robby Benson Robby Benson
walk proud that's the one way he plays
in native is he's a runner right okay so
what would you work in arnelle's
just those three books and the
documentary with me and cartoon and then
I got a couple little movie ideas that
I'm trying to push the line on but you
know I learned my lesson not to talk
about him because [ __ ] 10 years later
they don't come
idiot I know that Oh
seven years ago it did a Buddha didn't
want to talk about now it's coming out
but it's called taco shop shop Khatami a
fourth or look for it man
I have no lines what happened bro you
got your seat no they cut my parts yeah
you need somebody who's got ideas who
can say hey I want this guy yeah or just
an investor who's not you know yeah
who's just like yeah I believe in you
here's some money
go do your thing you know I'm not gonna
[ __ ] with you and break your balls and I
just want you to you know do your best
someone the head of bringing their niece
in the middle of moving goes put her in
writer apart homie give me some lines so
you were non Daschle with Anthony
Bourdain yeah a couple of times once
with with David David Choe David show
and then the next time with me in
cartoon where'd you get eat at it was a
shop that got closed down as called
Lorena on 7th and Mateo
there was this elderly woman there that
used to bring a card out at nighttime
and she used to make bomb food and then
something happened between her and the
youngsters at work with her and she
ended up quitting and then we just
didn't go back there no more and then
they closed down that place and it's
gonna be like it's right next to that
ice cream museum I think it might be a
cotton candy museum now or something who
knows I used to work down there my first
job was right there are six when you get
when you go down the bridge on 6th
Street there were 50 bridge the 5th
Street bridge right there's 4th 4th 6th
and 7th 7th Street bridge yeah I still
don't you go over the bridge another
name of that street
yeah but nice to kind of things kind of
fade my first job was right to the right
I used to work at apex bro loading
produce from 11 o'clock at night
no break yeah we used to live right
there I mean cartoon across free from
leeches the death threat look he said
the movie are talking about was Duke
overall they presented the project
behind a wall yeah I grew up in Pico Ali
so actually because of Pico Gardens but
then I babe I wonder than Pico Ali so
then we both live in Pico Ali so you
were like Europe in a bad neighborhood
with a lot of shootings no not really uh
I mean like now even the neighborhood we
live in now there's like a helicopter
over us every every week you know it
sounds like it's gonna land in my
backyard
there's always some [ __ ] going on that's
the the SWAT teams running through our
our yard about two times already full
you know yeah with the with the ar-15 is
out and the dogs and all that we're like
man are we getting raided but they're
they're like I don't know we're looking
for somebody to drove a stolen car and
they ran in through your yard you know
at first I was like yeah right you guys
just want to see what I do but yeah I
guess you know now she's just buck wild
everywhere it feels like you know do you
or your kids about photography also know
none of the I tell my kids all the time
they can you turn the you know turn your
phone like straight and lease or you
know can you do something like your for
your the photographer's daughter you
know that block well I said oh you know
private message so I don't put him on
blast on that on their pages you know
like hey can you do this a little better
like that one daughter likes to work out
I was like hey can you turn the camera
this way so all my friends aren't you
know looking like you know at that angle
okay sorry dad but uh you know you you
always hope the best for your kids you
know me and my wife always told our kids
the same all four of them you know get
good grades in school work hard you know
don't do drugs don't have unprotected
sex and you know that never that didn't
work out what's up with Joker brand is
that I still make a little bit you know
here and there Joker brand it's on my
website it's just little pieces here and
there and then we sell some of it I have
a distributor in Germany and he covers
the European part of it but they don't
own the company they just know they just
distribute for us it's like a licensing
thing but they do real nice [ __ ] over
there they do it the right way over
there you know you forget your trademark
and everything done in Germany as well
yeah if you want anything trademark you
like to do there's guys in Guadalajara
they're just bootleg the [ __ ] China does
it to it you have to get specific
lawyers and yeah they have like videos
and guys rapping in the videos and
they're singing about Joker and
everything and and then I wrote on their
a like don't support the the fake you
know bootleg Joker brand company and
they're like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and you know we are Joker Joker's are
[ __ ] I go my boy drew that [ __ ] in 1995
you know who did you have dry you know
that and I have we don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you know all right cool
though death before the spit on it
yeah
we'll just take her art is when I first
one I'm Last Comic Standing
someone I've bought Felipe Esparza calm
yeah man wait beside to me for five g's
yeah a fan yeah I got a guy that has a
joker brand Instagram won't let me get
it on Joker brand as a brand like
copyright you can fight that then
marketing everything yeah you can send
them you can send a cease-and-desist
letter to the Registrar of that website
and they'll give it to you that's what I
did that's what I did with Felipe
Esparza but it took a few years but I
got it yeah along with every other
[ __ ] thing you have to do after here
I'm going to go to my where out then I
got to go downtown and buy some bling
shirts and take them to Santa Fe Springs
of the printer and bring them back here
to the printers like oh yeah and then I
got to send that paperwork you know I
know look that's my day I just don't
understand how somebody considered a fan
of somebody then they jackass yeah I
know could you imagine like buying a
website and then asking for money for I
see you people that want free photos too
though hey do you know how much time it
takes to fill up lies well they think
the years still that [ __ ] just on
Instagram which people do but that's
great you make a book and you plug this
from yourself yeah yeah so good coffee
book my love like book you know how many
photos he goes through I mean how many
do you on average you go through for one
great photo that you grab out of there
it's taken yeah I have about for between
400 and 500 thousand photos that I've
taken in my whole career so when they go
hey you know we need we want a book to
put out it's hard to choose the best
ones Kim Kardashian we fortunately
famous yeah so you probably hate that
cuz it you know it's not it's like
autograph oh you know it's about how she
looks now okay
little booth on that one huh it's a
first but
first but yeah but number one little
silver pin over here in a quick question
in regard it's a house of pain getting
kicked off that tour with Beastie Boys
what was it like one incident or they're
just too rowdy and like oh it was the
tour manager or the Beastie Boys for the
Beastie Boys he gave every last mom
tickets like in the grass
hail at the top of the of the
amphitheater and she called and she was
like hey honey you know like I got me in
the show and he's like where are you in
she was where I'm up here in the grass
you know if you'd look up at the top of
the thing that you know where the where
the lights shining on the guys at the
stage that's where I man he blew his lid
I know he was like what the [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] give my mom the
[ __ ] lawn seats and she yeah the lawn
sees the [ __ ] and you know he went in
and told the guy piece of his mind and
and they the next day we're off the tour
down over there's like you know before
they're you know punk rockers and you
know hip-hop nobody be like that
sensitive you know fight for your right
to party issues yeah like you know fight
for the right for your mom to see your
[ __ ] concert you know it's like
that's I didn't think he was asking too
much you know right and and yeah he had
the right to be a little upset like you
your mom's gonna go to he's like that
was probably one of the first shows that
she was gonna see especially with the
full [ __ ] crowd you know so he wasn't
asking too much you know for that guy to
you know be a power trip yeah oh you're
gonna come my office and be
disrespectful I'll have your ass thrown
up tours I don't like some wait baby
but [ __ ] it it didn't hurt him he's you
know blew up and they're saying that
spot was 7 minutes opening yeah I was a
rabbit it was like an intro for like a
couple minutes and then jump around
Wow then it took off you know nothing
that was what to check your head tours
out already ill communication no
communication yeah I think it was a
little communication sabotage days yeah
I saw I saw the BC boys for the first
time with Madonna in 19 I think it was
84 in San Diego uh you seen that is that
the like of urgent or is that the tour
after I think that was like a virgin
because they have that big Budweiser
blow-up that's in that's licensed that
was theirs back when they were doing
their own thing so that's okay that's it
that's before they even were [ __ ] rap
rap yeah yeah pretty kooky [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like when they're what's your l7 l7
she was the drummer drummer Kaitlin
luscious Jackson and the l7 I think but
she was in their band - I can't remember
what they're called they're called the
the new they were called quays all right
but then they were Beastie Boy before
because they were doing the hardcore
stuff for a while like yeah as of late
you know before homeboy passed so that
you seen him back then in that tour yeah
a young young Aborigines he goes in a
balboa park it was like some
amphitheater that was there
Madonna was playing they opened up for
her how was Madonna she was you know
that was in her prime back then yeah
what's a fool what some other real
Torres not to do to let go with a Y mm
bro yeah man all right were some fool
your shows coming up on April 19 and
we're on Terry I'm profiteer probably ed
ones that one they say Oh show coming up
dishes right
I have to put all the new dates on your
website I don't have to order new merch
I have to finish reconciling the the
first quarter so I can pay your sales
tax for the first quarter I have you
want me to list everything thank you
sitting here with us yeah they having a
good time come people do buy that book
the one I have in my hand yeah they can
get it from my publisher in Italy okay
old used to have your store limit to
cartooning your store with the hoodies
no that was this a pop-up shop we didn't
downtown flowers our photo okay for the
[ __ ] yeah now they raised our rent like
three times and we were like see you
know and that was after like some of the
homeless people would come one of the
guys one time he calls up and he goes
hey yo there's a lady shooting in front
of the store but what do you mean
because they'd like the door cut in the
door the doorway she had backed her ass
up to the door [ __ ] on it and wiped her
ass and threw her paper through the
through the mail slot on the door that's
a standing ovation or Salvador well
where's your where can they find you on
your Instagram yes just my name is
Stefan Oriole I want to make that you
out that yeah and then I got a Stefan
Oriole shop in the LA woman book are all
the accounts that I work with on
Instagram nothing with Joker brand there
no I got a joker brand Twitter I just
use that on Twitter you know cuz uh just
try to keep [ __ ] on live you know was so
full thank you for having well have it
and a continued success and keep shining
and thank you very much for doing what
you did yeah thank you
yep oh yeah make it one